the streets in the capital Beijing are
almost empty and they'll most likely
stay that way until next Monday
now that the Lunar New Year holiday has
been extended to help curb the spread of
the coronavirus more countries and
territories have increased restrictions
on people from Hebei province or even
ban their entry in some cases as the
Chinese government continues with its
plan on containing and treating those
who have the virus
I have to keep wearing the same masks if
I throw this away
I have no masks then I'm asking the
government to sell more masks I found
out that everything sold out hard to buy
food and vegetables now I hope the
situation can get better after the
Chinese New Year holiday China's second
most powerful government official
Premier Li Keqiang has been put in
charge of the coronavirus situation he
traveled down to Wuhan and visited the
construction site of a hospital that's
been purpose-built for the virus we
should build this hospital as soon as
possible we set the date as February 2nd
we bringing all the medical resources
from all over the country
we'll bring thousands of medical staff
to other hospitals in here he then spoke
with medical workers on the front lines
of the virus outbreak stay safe and save
lives because what you're doing now is
to save lives
the old nation is relying on you while
the people of China might be relying on
those medical workers the entire world
watches as the number of dead and
infected continues to rise
Scott Heidler al-jazeera Beijing